شبح هو فيروس كورونا يعود ل يبث الرعب
والقلق في النفوس نعيدا الى الاذهان مشاهد
بدايه الجائحه التي هزت العالم واوقفت
حركته على امتداد نحو عامين الوضع يبدو
مقلقا في الصين في ظل الاعتراف بارتفاع
الاصابات في مشهد شبيه بخريف عن 2019 ذروه
تفشل وباء نحو 250 مليون اصابه بكرونا
خلال 20 يوما رقم مخيف يعكس الانتشار
السريع للعدوى خلال هذه الفتره من السنه
وهو رقم يعادل 18% من سكان البلاد
استدعاء اربعه اربعه سوق هذا الاسبوع افضل
بكثير من الاسبوع الماضي لقد بلغ ذروته في
الثانيه عشر من الشهر الجاري عند مصطفى
حوالي 240 الى 350 شخصا خارج المستشفى
لتلقي العلاج والان العدد يتراوح بين 240
و 200 250 كان الناس ينتظرون حوالي ثلاثا
الى اربع ساعات الان يستغرق الامر حوالي
نصف ساعه
ومن الان فصاعدا لن يكون متاحا التعرف على
اعداد الاصابات في الصين بعد ما اعلنت
اللجنه التابعه للصحه الوطنيه في البلاد
التوقف عن نشر البيانات اليوميه للاصابات
وذلك دون تحديد السبب وراء هذا القرار
كانت الصين قد رفعت التدابير صحيه صارمه
المتعلقه بسياسه في الاسبوع الاول من شهر
ديسمبر الجاري وهو ما ادى الى الارتفاع
الكبير في عدد الاصابات
من موجه اشد لمتحول اوميكرون الصين